[Music]
so this is what we were trying to play
yesterday before we
got cut off um and i wanted to play
before we were literally
raped there was a click on youtube there
was a clip of this that we were playing
yesterday from this episode and it was
from like some other thing and it was uh
you know
uh tom segura calls brendan shaw
delusional but today i went to go pull
the video up for prep and it wasn't
there so i had to actually go into his
episode to find it but i found it
so uh
yeah so what they're talking about here
because with samples a bunch of [ __ ]
before they're talking about how like
when these you know movie stars that
used to be comics are just pretty much
movie stars now but they show up at
comedy clubs sometimes yeah you know and
then they get on stage before people
okay that's the setup here you go we're
way smaller percentage like of all the
celebrities and well-known people i
opened for i would say like 10 to 15
percent were really good comedians but
those 10 to 50 percent now are probably
way bigger yeah because they're the ones
it's a marathon
exactly you know how to you'll see
someone with [ __ ] material people like
oh they're in this movie or yeah you did
this show and you know who they are we
don't need to name them and even at the
comment store you'll see them they'll
pop in yeah they're sandwiched between
real comics you're like oh you
you mean like you brendan
yeah mean like you you mean how you're
sandwiched in between real comedians you
mean how you think because you were
given a showtime special because you're
[ __ ] joe rogan's friend and you made
a youtube special that took you five
takes to put 20 at 25 minutes
so
no not b he also had that tight-ass bit
about the mountain lion
thank you oh and sometimes when those
now now that like we know what we're
doing and know what i'm looking at when
i feel like a straight
sponsored by bud light seltzer lemonade
yeah papa's got some nice cabs
yeah oh yeah the celebrity comic popping
like you're getting all i'm gonna say i
still can't get over that [ __ ] stupid
uh the fighter and the kid uh that post
in the subreddit oh yeah they're just
they're doing product reviews as brendan
shaw it's so good on like walmart.com
and it was just like literally just
under pringles and it's just the guy's
name is brendan chubb and he's like
talking about these sh tombow these
joints was fire b
i had to walk them back to my drug
i'm gonna eat [ __ ]
tom segura looks like if ethan klein
looked human
yes oh i see it yeah i see what you're
saying yeah like the skin
properly
yep that's right if the skin suit fit
properly
also he kind of looks like jack murphy
if jack murphy wasn't over compensating
and trying to look super alpha all the
time right like a normal jack murphy
yeah like a jack murphy that's like yeah
i'm a [ __ ] so what
do
you
do
ethan klein tom segura and [ __ ] jack
murphy are three evolutions of a pokemon
yep yep
now that like we know what we're doing
and know what i'm looking at when i see
like the like a celebrity comic pop i'm
like you're gonna eat [ __ ] on this show
and i can't wait too much
i'm gonna
and i can't wait to watch this hold on
he never lets anyone talk do you notice
that no i don't i mean he doesn't
whenever you're talking
he does what he does
it is but you're right papa you're right
papa
it's infinite okay it is the worst
anyway i don't think you should do that
to him okay listen
okay check this out this is he's like
that joyo passy guy okay shut up
listen
now that like we know what we're doing
and know what i'm looking at when i see
like those like a celebrity comic pop
i'm like you're gonna eat [ __ ] on this
show and i can't wait too much
but when we can't wait to watch you eat
[ __ ] we're haters right according to
your to your
[ __ ] haters according to your
protector big gay lion
um we we're haters and we are not
allowed to watch you eat [ __ ] but you
could watch these stars eat [ __ ] which
by the way even any hack person that's a
movie guy is still probably funnier than
you i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna sit i'm
gonna sit around for this yeah yeah i'm
gonna make sure you see me yeah after
you're set so you know i saw it too yeah
so you know yeah and then i just go by
all these comics think the [ __ ] that
they are like remember the member well
who was bro they're not civilians
they're in the trenches dude stavros is
the one that called out
right that was the one yeah that was
great that was one of my favorite like
you may have don't say [ __ ] civilians
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no i was out you see
tom though they like tom
stavros the guy who left calm down never
did her last episode with the guys and
now everybody's pretending like
everybody's all cool
i mean that's not gross kind of weird
right
yeah
they're like tom knows it was it's funny
too because like you you realize that
you can end up like that meaning that
you can end up being like well
if i'm known enough i can you can like
get away with it you know so short-lived
though it's so short-lived
cause when you think about it there's
comics out there
those famous comics
celebrities who sell tickets and their
tickets you know a hundred dollars a
piece of 200 piece so you bring your
girl you only have 400 a night plus
dinner plus drinks so say 600 with
parking and babysitters 600 you better
be [ __ ] good yeah they get buddy that
math i don't know how expensive things
are in l.a
but if i go watch a [ __ ] even a
headliner i ain't spending 600 bucks so
what the [ __ ] are you even talking about
well i think he's talking about like the
famous ones i guess like the
you know yeah but even if i paid like he
just said a hundred dollars a ticket
right so even if i paid two hundred
dollars right
to go out no i said two hundred dollars
a ticket okay so even if i paid four
hundred dollars a ticket four hundred
dollars to go see a comic
um i don't think i'm gonna still [ __ ]
end up spending 600 but first off i'm
not going to spend 400. as far as i
start with that i ain't spending 400 to
see [ __ ] anybody but royce it's pablo
francisco
in a world in a world in a world in a
world i'm not a cocaine age you [ __ ]
bum you get off i'm not on cocaine
you're on cocaine
did i watch that again this morning it's
so good in a world in a world in a world
back home like you're all right then he
falls off the stage like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah no you want people
and by the way shout out to rumble you
know we're the second biggest [ __ ]
thing on your stupid platform and you
can't even put us on the front page hey
come on boys like whose dick do we gotta
suck for you to [ __ ] acknowledge us
acknowledge me
is that person for sure back yeah like
that was the best like and then and that
when they you do announce they're like
we bought on the [ __ ] pre-sale like
we we could not miss you yeah because
it's all about them coming back you know
that's what it is yeah i used to man i
so i i don't think i really i mean i
probably we all have like you know hints
of jealousy and stuff when you're
especially when you're young you're like
how's that person get that you know but
i think
every one of these shows just becomes
let's talk about comedy i just i my
point is like
i i don't
why do they always end up talking about
comedy because look man in their hearts
there's nothing going on outside of this
in their hearts these la comics
think that they are
doing something bigger than what they're
doing the way they talk they think
they're different tier of people than
the normal person on the streets so
that's all they talk about because look
let's face it like stavros said this too
he goes i became a comic because i'm
really bad at everything else you know
and that's the truth like what do you
have to fall back on like do a podcast
like everybody else we do a podcast too
and that's fine but
it's it's this arrogance it's this
arrogance that they have about them that
kind of really and i'm not talking about
segura specifically i'm just talking
about l.a comics in general have this
air of superiority over like the [ __ ]
civilians i don't have that well
because i think as i got in the game
later okay marsh
he got in the game later brendan got in
the game lately yeah a little too late
buddy yeah after your brain damage set
in
you know the only game you should have
been been in was a ufc game on xbox 360.
and after that that's about it
and there's not that and then all my
pairs like you guys are all his pairs
guy he said pears right
pears is in like the fruit yeah he meant
to say piers
oh and my pears and he said
i hate when you get like pear pressures
yeah i know seriously you know what i
went to pair one this weekend and bought
some furniture
in the game later you know
and there's not that and then all my
pairs like you got all my pairs
all my pairs everywhere all my pairs
as they're like so much more successful
so i'm like yeah of course they're
better yeah well they just do it longer
yeah that's what i'm saying it's like so
i think i took your approach where i
just learned like that's the way i just
soak it all yeah and then i it's not
it's not like oh i'm gonna be there i'm
like yeah i'll get there man oh yeah
it's a it's a marathon that's exactly
how i used to uh approach it because i
would just go like
i would why are you talking about
i want a mechanic when here's
here listen to me
when i take my car to a mechanic and he
tells me something is wrong
i want him to do his job and fix what's
wrong i don't need the mechanic i don't
need to listen to the mechanics sit
there with another mechanic and talk
about every nut and bolt and screw and
oil that they poured into the thing i
don't care nobody cares about your craft
and even if it was talking about the
craft of comedy if you were sitting
there talking about home comedy comedy
if you were talking to another comedy
pair
like louis ck for example or somebody
that would actually be interested in
hearing about them and then fine but you
guys are sitting there and you're
talking to [ __ ] brendan chubb he's
not a comedian
so why are you guys talking like you are
even doing the same job
you're not even doing the same job
look at my year and i'd be like alright
this year i featured at like let's say
20 clubs and i made you know or 30 000
or whatever it was
and i would go like the next year i just
was like i just wanted to be better than
this year yeah and like that that thing
was like this you know i ended up
featuring at 40 clubs this year and i
made twenty thousand dollars more yup so
i i would look so no wait hold on a
second
so remember when it was on coofs to like
talk about how much money you made
so now they're just bragging about how
much dough they make like i don't
understand la comedy i don't [ __ ] get
it
look at that as just progress
and just trying to like make that
progress happen by putting in work yep
so my thing now is like i'll look at a
like if we go back to a certain city
like if it's not selling more than i
didn't do my job that's not yeah it's
not the people so my the way i gauge
success now is so let's say i was in san
antonio two years ago i'm going there in
september so if i can't sell more in
september yeah then
i'm messing up it's on me yeah so like
so
like like so like i'm doing this new
thing right i'm doing this new thing so
like let's say i'm in like san diego i
tell them that san diego is the best
city
in in the in america and then they then
they clap
and i like when they clap
and then i
mention all my favorite mexican foods
that's how i engage all my success based
off
sales market yeah yeah i mean it's a
good way to see that it's moving along
on the business side and then you have
to ask like because i would always try
to go like am i doing am i writing
better material correct you know and
like that's usually the thing that only
you can really answer yep imagine if we
did an entire podcast just think about
this for a second imagine we did an
entire podcast where we talked about the
craft of podcasting
who who would care about that who's that
for um well civilians that don't ever
get a glimpse into that world
you know sometimes a lot of people don't
know this that uh when you're setting up
obs if you change the stream rate it
goes a little bit differently like other
people that don't you know they don't
have a podcast biz wouldn't get that
yeah you're right that that does sound
pretty shitty it's to see what i mean
[ __ ] that's what they're doing i
don't care tell the joke funny man
you know and it sometimes it makes you
have like tough conversations with
yourself but it's ultimately good i mean
you have to there's kind of like a pair
alone away with like athleticism
athletics in that way right where you're
black and white yeah where you're like
this conversation about athletics
yeah and you you know yeah [ __ ] you
lost me when brendan schaub says he
measures success by progress like the
[ __ ] i just oh i'm sorry buddy you're
not reading the same self-help book he
is
am i you know if you're a quarterback
it's a coloring book but he's really
good at it it's not a [ __ ] self-help
book it's just a [ __ ] it's he's just
reading mark harley's [ __ ] stamp
no no no no i'm sorry because that's
above his reading level you don't think
he can i think he could he can't clearly
read trust no [ __ ] which is probably
or whatever some gay [ __ ] like that
you guys uh he measures his success with
a golf scoring system i don't care
[Laughter]
this month he's got a birdie oh [ __ ]
he's winning all in one
quarterback's like am i scoring enough
touchdowns winning games yeah he sounds
like he had a couple penalty strokes
[Laughter]
keeps taking keeps insisting on
mulligans they're like
it's the sun is setting we've been at
hole three for like six hours okay come
on one more time come on papa come on
papa
it's like are they laughing am i selling
tickets yeah well no or they didn't
laugh at this
[Laughter]
brandon doesn't even bring a putter he
brings like one of those [ __ ] like uh
mini golf clubs
i'm about to say why are all of your
golf balls neon
yo yo bee so i can find them later at
night time well i don't think these are
regulation
one of the one of his friends leans to
his other friend he goes he keeps saying
he's excited to get to the giant
windmill i don't know [ __ ] he's sorry
they did the celebrity thing and they in
18 and and they and they teamed them up
with tiger woods and he kept asking him
when do i shoot the ball to the
alligator's mouth
bro you shoot the ball between the
clown's legs and then yo b it goes down
that weird tube you've just been playing
that board game gator golf get out of
here
i was partnered up
tiger woods was partnered up with bread
and shop when asked about the experience
mr woods said he kept poking me and
asking me if i remembered different
parts of happy kilmore
yo you remember when the alligator
bigger handle he's touching him he's
touching him
yo remember that movie marker hey bro
hey baby remember that movie uh uh uh
how howard gilmore
that where gavin mcginnis was golfing no
shooter mcgavin
[Laughter]
kevin mcinnis
yo wasn't he also in the proud boys b no
that's your that's gavin mcginnis
shooter mcgavin just got arrested for
dui and he said yeah and he said i was
god that's right he's like
i was in happy gilmore is what he told
them bro that's a rough career huh yeah
he was also in dirty work
yeah and you know great you can choose
that's the thing is one of those things
where you can choose
to be as delusional as you want to be
and we see
right in front of us the delusional
people i mean yeah well right in front
of you you have a delusional person i
promise right right in front of a
delusional person you have small
delusions to yourself we all do all the
time where you'll be you know like
something for example like
i'm joe rogan's friend and i'm actually
just a fighter should i be doing this
and then what happens is you go knobby
i'm too stupid to understand what you're
saying conscience so i'm gonna go be a
stand-up comic
joke is just kind of a happy yeah i
gotta drown out my conscience so i'm
gonna go try to get annie leaderman to
suck my dick in a raptor
yeah i know all about delusion i'm
delusion my keys every day
[Laughter]
damn it
yeah i almost lost my sponsors when
brian cowling had that new york times
earpiece
you'll just be like
i just won't work on that yeah you just
you know you'll know what sucks like
there's more there yeah and i'll be like
but that would take effort yeah so then
you just you know and then one day
you're like that joke [ __ ] and then
then you find well i don't know what
sure did to become the industry standard
of every single show because we use them
too but it's so funny no matter what
show it is now it's one of these
microphones
i don't know maybe because they're the
only company that makes a [ __ ] that
makes a good one they make the best mic
at that price point that's a really good
point that's all it is i mean you're not
it's just pound for pound if you're
gonna pay you know you're gonna pay more
than 200 bucks for a mic but you want to
pay like less than a thousand
yeah sure man if you go any better than
that than that mike yeah you're paying
like twelve hundred dollars yeah and
it's also kind of a waste of money if
you're just gonna sit in podcast jokes
yeah
it's also sure the other thing with
shares is you can beat the [ __ ] out of
them dude yeah
dress it i also think you know when you
look at specials these days
and this is what i want to talk you
either on or off here about this you can
answer this if you want
talking to you know you netflix and
economy central and showtime hbo you
talk about people in your shoes
special
and then their analytics you know ana
lakes that's what it i don't know lakes
and lakes
wonderful have you ever been to ana
lakes that's a beautiful region of
michigan wasn't anna lakes the name of a
character in twin peaks
anna lakes sounds like one of those
really bad 90s porn star names i was
just about to say i remember seeing anna
lakes take two dicks on a vhs once in
1997. anna lakes is a squirter yeah
apparently yeah yeah that's why anna
lakes is definitely a squirter and and
from michigan
it is it's pretty black and white yeah
we know michigan squirrels you know
queen anna lakes that i saw michigan
square queen anna lakes volume two
actually did you see anna lakes and anal
aches anal aches i did see ana lakes in
ana lakes
um
i got tongue tied and it's not what you
think it's her pegging dudes
yeah people stop watching
i mean i came
i heard anna lake's ana lakes took 50
takes
god damn it
dr zeus [ __ ]
28 minutes yeah they come some might
come back half come back some might
finish you might have the outliers to
finish it all but whether it's kevin
hart jerry seinfeld
it's the first the fifth show um
i need i need a brandon shop translator
stop watching 28 minutes yeah yet the
industry we're in people say you gotta
do an hour yeah on the road no doubt
people are paying money you gotta do an
hour dude but when we're looking at like
what people are watching so now he's
trying listen to this
he's trying to convince himself that a
25-minute special was long enough
but it's not bill burr's last special
was an hour and 23 minutes long
dude and it's actually a 25-minute
special is long enough for a youtube
thing if you're trying to get some buzz
if it's good right good point
not if it's terrible mm-hmm watching
why we keep the you know the the people
who run this industry keep pushing hours
to me is weird yeah well just because
when i hear 20 minutes i go and want you
to do 30. yeah
everyone should do 30. you want to do 30
though
you should
especially kind of i think we're married
to
we know that what you know
if you become a headliner you do an hour
right on the road on the road yeah what
what's funny though is that i mean at
netflix they have encouraged and
aggressively encouraged trimming down
these specials what do you think that is
no i server space
yeah really no i mean i honestly think
i'm joking but it does it does matter
i mean server space um the amount of
stuff that's on that i mean look
by the way i don't wanna i don't even
watch netflix specials anymore because
it's just a bunch of indian dudes like
or or like five asian guys i i this so
what what am i gonna watch on there you
know that was like the uh what nick
mullen said about eliza schlesinger he's
like yeah of course she had a successful
special if you [ __ ] turn on netflix
what are you gonna do it's just one hot
chick with no top on or like five
condescending indians okay that's really
funny
which one are you gonna click on one hot
chick with no top but it's actually very
funny that's what it was she's like
attractive chick with her tits out on
one or five condescending indians